welcome to the Columbia art and
technology lectures my name is Reinhold
Martin I don't teach in the School of
the Arts I in fact teachings in the
School of the Graduate School of
Architecture and but mark tribe wasn't
able to be here tonight and they asked
me to stand in for him in welcoming your
fourth speaker in this series at Manuel
de Landa my sort of opportunity to
introduce Manuel is perhaps not entirely
in Congress since he's been teaching
with us and the other side of the campus
since 1995 in filling the lecture halls
with radically philosophical courses on
on such topics as materials and honor
and urbanism so so it's great to sort of
cross the way here and have a chance to
in a way continue the conversation on
the other side of the university Manuel
de Landa was born in 1952 in Mexico City
and has lived in Manhattan as the
official part since 1975 he began his
career in the mid 70s as an independent
filmmaker showing his films and cinah
clubs and museums around the world in
1980 he strategically acquired an
industrial-grade computer and became a
programmer and computer artist we're
just hearing about seagrass and what
1980s added to it right writing his own
software for several years he has also
written he writes in that sense at many
levels many philosophical essays which
have appeared in in numerous journals
and he lectures extensively in the
United States and Europe on nonlinear
dynamics theories of self-organization
artificial intelligence and artificial
life among other subjects
he is the author as you probably know of
the important books war on in the age of
intelligence machines a thousand years
of nonlinear history the great color and
intensive science and virtual philosophy
and Icke in 2000 2001 Manuel was also a
fellow at the Institute for Advanced
Studies at Princeton another kind of
interesting combination if you know that
institution and tonight's lecture will
be Dilla's
and use of the genetic algorithm in art
so and and market also just asked me to
remind you that the art and technology
lectures will continue Ricardo Dominguez
on May 12th and indeed you'll find video
streams of all the lectures in this
series online at the website of the
digital media center so please join me
in welcoming Manuel de Landa hey
everyone the point of this lecture this
is the this is my first class of the
second semester at Columbia I'm going to
adapt a little bit to to a new audience
the main point of the lecture is to
introduce the basic ideas of the flow of
the French philosopher geo de lewis
which as you know comes from the same
generation as many other postmodern and
philosophers in France but unlike those
postmodern philosophers the Lewis is a
materialist philosopher to begin with is
someone who believes the world exists
independently of our minds which is more
than I can say for most other postmodern
philosophers you know for me not in most
other philosophies that come from the
continent of Europe basically we create
the world by cutting it out with
language or with concepts and they
concentrate mostly on phenomenology the
list doesn't write one word about
phenomenology he wrote his very first
book on Hume meaning he buys a
completely different theory of
experience and of sensation which of
course ends up having repercussions in
its ideas about art so I want his
company his materialism it's very timely
it's very good that we finally had a new
materialism to replace the old
dialectical materialism based on Hegel
since the left needs rejuvenation needs
needs some fresh new ideas and they have
to be based on a materialist philosophy
idealism doesn't matter what postmodern
people say is an inherently inherently
conservative ideology but materialism
has demonstrated for many decades now to
be a progressive philosophy the problem
is in
needs to be based on science it needs to
be based not an uncritical acceptance of
science science needs to be approached
critically but of course we need to
always go to the experts won't matter
the problem with the old materialism is
that the only type of material entity
that it included was physical labor the
physical labor of the working class
where the true materialism needs to give
matter its due on the other hand I want
to also and this is just a way of kind
of giving these ideas it's likely more
relevant touch in a kind of computer art
type of way and I'm going to be linking
this with ideas about the genetic
algorithm the genetic algorithm is
basically a soft piece of software
that's relatively old now is born in
this 1960s which mimics evolution it's
sort of like virtual evolutionary
processes in the computer they even
though it sounds relatively new it isn't
some parts of Windows 95 which is
already an old piece of software were
actually bred you know bred like you
breed dogs like wait people breed race
horses bred through successive
generations in which they programmer
instead of writing code by hand what's
actually you're steering the evolution
the way in which a dog breeder does you
know a dog breeder begins of course this
is an ideal case you know with mongrel
dogs a bunch of mongrel dogs let's
assume of course that's not the way it
actually works mongrel dogs have all the
genes for all the different dogs our
different dog styles but combined and
with it and the tasks of the dog breeder
is of course to extract designs from
that mongrel by picking neighbor
generation for instance for certain
physical or behavioral traits who can be
picking for smaller size smaller size
smaller size and more and more and more
obnoxious and you end up with a
chihuahua dog or you can be picking for
larger and larger size and hairier and
perhaps a kind of a an altruistic
disposition you end up with the San
Bernard and the idea is that all this
design
are implicated or they're in the mongrel
dog and so there is a certain weighing
with that certain sense in which art can
actually be done via or artists can
utilize evolutionary processes as one
more tool not to replace them but simply
as one more - one more visualization
tool that they can bring to the task of
creating computer art as I was saying
Windows 95 which is already seven or
almost ten years old some of it very
very small pieces at pieces a deal is
called they're called drivers the ones
that interface directly with a printer
with a modem that need to be
particularly efficient we're bred this
way that we're not programmed by hand so
the genetic algorithm is relatively all
is already part of industry so it's
there's nothing new about it what's know
about it in a sense is its utilization
by artists and so I want to be talking
about that too so let me first introduce
a little bit few ideas on the loses
materialism they a one of the main
reasons why most post modern
philosophers went idealist that is
everything is done with language
everything is a text everything is just
a matter of interpretation in a semantic
kind of way is because when you assert
that the world exists in the penalty of
our minds you end up being an
essentialist
in other words if you believe that
hydrogen atoms exist in the penalty of
our minds that dogs exist in plenty of
our minds at clouds and mountains
existence plenty of our minds what
guarantees their identity what makes
them maintain that mind independent
identity well an essence hydrogen atoms
have an essence which makes them what
they are mountains have an essence
mountain hood which makes them what they
are and so clearly that is unacceptable
that is just to reintroduce a kind of
kind of idealism into into a fake
materialism no wonder so many people so
many philosophers in the twentieth
century went idealist they didn't want
to have anything to do with essences so
the novelty of the list is having
created a new materialism which gets rid
of essences basically
essentialism has many faces but one of
them is a theory of the genesis of form
this is why it's very important to
artists since artists are involved in
the genesis of form and the processes
that that give birth to new forms
essentialism basically says matter and
energy are inert they do not have
anymore for genetic capabilities they
cannot give rise to new forms on their
own forms come from a world of essences
or from the mind of God creationism is
another form of idealism another form of
essentialism in and they are form begins
as a concept the mind of God and then
it's imposed on this inert matter who
can do anything but just sit there as a
command let there be light let there be
animals and plants let there be form
form cannot emerge from matter itself so
the loose turns this around and says
what the last 30 years of science in
nonlinear dynamics fractal theory Cal's
theory theories of self-organization and
complexity and so on have demonstrated
beyond any doubt is that matter is more
for genetically charged that it has
powers of morphogenesis of their own and
that this should somehow alter the
position of the artist with respect to
his or her materials the artist can play
the role of God of course and have an
image cerebral project excluded that
that is well this is the form I want to
create them by more or less domesticated
materials like mild steel or other forms
of industrial metals which have become
almost inert and then impose a form on
that particular sculpture on the
particular piece of metal or the artist
can recognize that materials have powers
creative powers of their own and enter
into a partnership with the materials in
the genesis of form my favorite example
here is the architect Frei Otto Frye
Otto is a German architect who worked
for a long time and stood
Institute for lightweight structures he
was responsible for the tent-like roofs
of the Munich Olympics in 68 and the way
he designed because this is before
computers or as computers we're coming
along he could have used computer
graphics you know 3d computer and made a
computer package just to create those
beautiful shapes that make his tent like
roofs but he didn't have access to that
so what he did is he used so film that's
like you know one of the most humble
materials that you find in your kitchen
and your bathroom you know to a system
in the calculation of the forms soap
because it's more for genetically
pregnant although those very very simple
things has already tendencies it's not
inert so film all you have to do is blow
a little bit on it and the sphere comes
out all by itself you know how hard it
is for artists to create real spheres
you know how hard it was for Buckminster
Fuller to come up with his geodesics in
a spherical form and so does it all by
itself all you had to do is blow of
course he didn't want a sphere he wanted
taint lie proof so he needed to put
something on himself
so what he did is basically I you know I
don't know there are products we use I
imagine him in slippers and in his
bathroom you know he took a piece of
plywood put little people of course was
going to design this at scale a smaller
scale
he put little wooden sticks where the
columns that would eventually hold this
tent like roof would be loosely hanging
threads attach the tips of the other
columns to serve as constraints on the
soap lower this this art of this this
thing into the bathtub then pull it out
very carefully through the surface so
it's not to break the soap and the soap
have magically computed the surfaces for
him because soap tends by itself to
minimize surface tension that is what
film soap film does and when you don't
constrain it that minimization that
tendency results in a sphere but when
you do constrain it it results in a
variety of shapes which are also minimal
shapes which are always beautiful
now that's an example of an artist
entering into a partnership with the
materials he didn't try to come up with
the forms in his head and then impose
them on a bunch of workers and say well
no I want this you have to come up with
it it was a kind of interaction with the
materials what he recognized in fact he
uses the word form finding for his
little setups and his little assemblages
where he gets materials to do a little a
little bit of the design for him and in
a way this is what the list has all the
time being talking about not only for
art but in general for industry for
economics for sociology the material
aspect of our lives and material aspects
of our cities are meshing with
environment you know in a more
irrational or at least less irrational
way needs to take into account the flows
of genes through generations the flows
of flesh or biomass through food chains
the flows of water the flows of air and
until we begin to create a partnership
with the material world instead of
trying to impose our will preconceived
will on this material world we are in
trouble so that is basically his
materialism I'm going to give you in
more details about this now the genetic
algorithm the genetic algorithm is
simply as I said a simulation of
evolution in the computer it can only be
applied for the same reason to art done
in the computer so for the time for the
rest of this lecture I'm going to assume
that some of you at least utilize the
computer this doesn't mean that the
final product needs to be computer
graphics or computer music or computer
anything you can be using the computer
as an intermediate step to something
like if you're a choreographer and you
are using the computer to you know with
little stick figures to create some
movements and so on and you're just
using them as an intermediate step in
the design process of your choreography
that would still count or it can be the
type of computer artists whose final
output is a computer output but the
computer needs to be involved at some
point or another obviously otherwise the
genetic algorithm would not be appliable
second it can only be applied to our
in which the artistic element design
elements with the brushstrokes and a
painting the notes and motifs and so on
in a piece of music the the different
bodily movements in a choreography the
the different spatial components in a
sculpture are defining the computer not
via clicking with the mouse which is the
way most of us do it but procedurally
you know most programs for a shop
myalgia 3d now come with little script
writing capabilities of course most of
us are you know not well I became a
hacker very early on in my life the
introduction just said yeah so I learned
how to program in the early eighties but
I was forced to do that because my
computer that I had just spent my family
fortune on and didn't do anything back
then you couldn't buy software so I was
forced and I was kicking and screaming
brought into the comp into the
programming world but then I realized
after a couple of years of pain that it
was the best thing that could have
happened to me because for the first
time I understood process I understood
how the computer tongue used to specify
processes how algorithms which are
simply mechanical recipes can be used to
specify a process that in turn generates
a particular formal element this process
approach to computer art is now becoming
more and more a well-known in the sense
that the software packages themselves
come with this is scripting capabilities
before you either you have to click and
you know mouse and click your way
through through through through the
process now you can do it with a mouse
or a tablet or whatever other input
devices you have or you can begin to
think in terms of process it involves
not math but a little bit of formal
thinking because you need to learn about
loops and and how to represent processes
within a computer language but it pays
in the end because you can do many
things that you could not do by clicking
and mousing around specifically you can
create works of art that then lend
themselves to performance since every
single element of the work of art is
produced in the computer and you can
interact and intervene in it changing
parameters changing
and so honestly produces it lends itself
to a to a wider variety of applications
than just clicking and mouthing it a
regardless of that I'm not going to go
into that specifically it is absolutely
necessary to apply the genetic algorithm
that the elements of design are
specified as a process it's a little
program because it is those programs
that play the role of genes in the
computer and that generate what what
comes out on the other side examples of
this include there's a British artist
who is a sculpture his name is William
Latham LH am I recommend that you read
his book on genetic art he has very
pretty pictures I've been doing computer
modeling for a long time 3d modeling I
did that for a living for a long time
that's how I pay for my books my books
cost me money they don't really make I
don't really make any money out of those
suckers and I remember when I opened
William Layton's book for the first time
and I thought oh my god he did not even
model he did not even touch with the
mouse one of this little complex
creatures he actually bred them he began
because he gives you the genealogical
trees with a grand grand grand
grandparents and you know and so why
don't you see that he begins with a
larvae kind of looking things and then
they begin sprouting you know arms and
weird things you know and then at the
end he picks one you know like a dog
breeder he picks his little chihuahua
dog of a sculpture and it's what is the
final product ah interesting but I want
to tell you some limitations precisely
this is where the list comes in I remove
the limitations of the software what
kind of philosophical resources need to
be brought in addition to the software
to make this work another example his
name is blind
John blind it's a musician a jazz
musician and as a jazz musician he was
accustomed to interacting with humans as
everybody knows jazz musicians play on
each other's music you know and as the
clarinet is finishing a particular line
it goes okay take it away sax and the
sax needs to kind of have heard the last
few notes or the last few bars of the
and then exploited for melodic ideas and
then you be
and jamming with the other person doing
that now blinds wanted to do the same
thing with a computer he wanted to
travel around jazz clubs playing with a
computer but he knew that if the
computer just played canned melodies the
audience was going to get bored he was
gonna get bored he was gonna have
absolutely anything in any kind of
rapport with the other participant
because it was just plain canned music
but he himself had put in so he took a
genetic algorithm to breed melodic
pieces melodic lines in real time the
computers constantly listen to the human
performer he's he's a piece of software
by the way it's called gen Jam Janus in
genetic jammers in a jam session Jen Jen
Jen Jen now plays in jazz clubs and it's
accepted as a human because it's not bad
it's not a bad player and they hope
though that what's interesting is that
every single melody that comes out of
Genzyme speakers is bred like a
Chihuahua dog now to me that signals
that something new is in the offing here
there's of course other other artists
that have utilized this they are in fact
urban planners John Fraser a British
urban planner has utilized genetic
algorithms to breed proposals for new
developments of cities it can be used at
different scales again the most
important thing is the elements need to
be specified as a process for sculptors
this is rather simple because everything
you create in a CAD system in a 3d CAD
system it's simply a sequence of
instructions so for instance you want to
create a column you're an architect that
you want to begin creating a fancy
column well the first step is to draw
the outline of the column the second
step is to spin it to rotate to create a
square it's called a surface of
revolution which is now a kind of
cylindrical type shape where the shape
or the profile that you drew then you
can make some carvings to give it some
miracles but it's called boolean
functions to carve out some decorations
in the column it's a process it's a
sequence of instructions that generates
a column the sequence of instructions
can then be stored
and become the DNA of the work of art of
course there's got to be one for each
one of the elements in that particular
architectural piece so software is it
software writers software creators the
people who sell this stuff like
Photoshop the parent company or
Photoshop and so on Adobe I think it's
called are beginning to realize that
they need to give artists more power
over their software otherwise the
software imposes its look on the artists
everybody has seen stuff that's
Photoshop to death in a Wired magazine
used to be a little bit like that you
know what you could say well that you
know I can even see the filters that is
I apply here
I need a sequence of the filters and
everything and that is not good for
artists because that constrains you so
learning how to write even simple script
it's a good thing because that you begin
to take over the software you begin to
impose now a little bit of your own will
on the software instead of some software
designer in California or somewhere you
know telling you what to do it's hard at
first because it's unfamiliar territory
but it pays in the end believe me you
know I always tell my students this in
the first day of class or maybe I'm
getting a little too pedagogics here
let's all be hackers people anyway how
do we blend these two things how do
these two things have to do with one
another the neo materialism achill
dealers and the genetic algorithm well
they have to do with one another because
genes out there in nature or even inside
our own sperm and eggs count on the fact
that matter is active in order to
generate all the variety of natural
forms that we see around us plants
animals insects microorganisms and so on
genes do not specify the genes are not a
representation of the final form as if
it were a blueprint an iconic
representation was going to come out and
therefore matter is not as if genes we
are now like God telling matter what to
do commanding might do this so that
genes piece out a form out of materials
which have their own Morpho genetic
potential and evolution has been able to
do what it has been a
to do only and exclusively because of
that more for genetic potential if it
was all up to genes would still be all
microbes complexity can only beat East
out of matter in certain ways and so if
that is necessary in nature it clearly
is necessary in the computer we need to
bring certain ideas from new materialism
delusional materialism to the computer
for the genetic algorithm to actually
perform its job
glues virus from science three forms of
thinking through reasoning styles which
I've Monaco population thinking
intensive thinking and topological
thinking each one comes from a different
branch of science the first one comes
from evolutionary biology was created
basically population thinking in the
1930s when the ideas of Darwin and and
Mendel were for the first time blended
together intensive thinking comes from
thermodynamics 19th century
thermodynamics as well as 20th century
thermodynamics topological thinking
comes from mathematics and
mathematicians thermodynamics is
evolutionary biologists each one has
that reasoning style which has served
them well in their own disciplines but
precisely because of the
interdisciplinary boundaries that define
this are over specialized Academy they
do not communicate with one another the
clearly are some ecologists who need a
little bit of thermodynamics a little
bit of evolutionary biology and blended
two but no one has really blended these
three radically different styles of
thinking which emerged in the you know
in the 20th century or that require the
final shape in the 20th century and so
we need a philosopher this is in a way
what philosophers do they do synthesis
they get the best out of one specialty
they get the best out of another
specialty they jump over a silly
academic boundaries that define fields
that are maybe at war with one another
because you know such a sociology
department wants more money that the
economics department now cannot get them
and and then they now they back mailed
each other you know economists are all
for rational chose oh yeah sociology or
for ritual and ceremony
we need both we both make choices and
follow routines so we need sociology
within economics and so the same thing
goes for the rest of science the
philosophers can bring something new to
science which is a synthesis revealing
something that scientists themselves may
not have seen in their own over
specialized blindness don't let me
explain how these three forms of
thinking work first population thinking
population thinking basically says that
in order for evolution to take place you
always need a large reproductive
community Adam and Eve one work you
cannot start with two entities of that
particular kind there's just not enough
space for the mutations to propagate
there's not enough space for the
variation that that that drives
evolution I remember that
what evolution the way in which
evolution are destroyed essences at
least in biology is that essentialist
are is totally an essentialist in
particular used to think of you know for
instance you see a population of zebras
there is somewhere an essence of zebra
hood zebra hood is a list of traits that
make a zebra what it is that give a
zebra its identity there is the perfect
zebra the one that meets all the
specifications and then there's only
imperfect imperfect zebras that we see
with variations in camouflage and height
and so on you have to get past the
heterogeneity past the difference past
the imperfections to reach the perfect
zebra population thinking says it's
exactly the other way around
imperfections are crucial heterogeneity
and variation is what drives evolution
you homogenize a population say through
biotechnology or some capitalist
agriculture and you stop evolution in
its tracks heterogeneity difference is
is crucial to the process and needs to
be valued because on because natural
selection which is just a filter all it
can eat this is just a mechanical filter
just less certain genes pass certain
genes not pass the moment all the genes
are the same it has nothing to filter
nothing
sort out so for the first time
evolutionary biologists brought us a
positive idea of difference a positive
idea of heterogeneity a valuable form of
variation which is absolutely needed and
so population thinking also allows us to
go past the cliches of Darwinism in the
19th century which degenerated into
really bad politics with social
Darwinism such as survival of the
fittest or struggle for survival or
things like that that made it seem as if
you know a winner-takes-all and
evolution is all about you know
blood and nature red and claw and and
and tooth and claw or something like
that whereas in fact there are many many
acne ecological strategies their
symbiosis
there's predator-prey relationships that
have nothing to do with competition and
clear and another point that is very
important is there's no such thing as
the fittest the fittest assumes that
that there's only one best design it's
going back to essentialism the essence
of the zebra and then natural selection
just brings us to that perfect zebra
today population thinkers realize that
there is in fact multiple equilibria
that most species are trapped in local
optima that there is no such thing as
the best design
so population thinking has switched the
slogan of Darwinism from survival of the
fittest or one of those silly ones to
evolution is an automatic search process
it automatically searches a space of
possibilities the genetic algorithm is
classified in computer science as a
search algorithm search algorithms
search recipes are extremely important
in computer science not only because
every time a new one gets invented some
Google guy gets becomes millionaire but
because just about every operation that
you have to do in your computer demands
searching when you save a file the
computer needs to search the hard disk
for empty space you can be searching for
word searching for files themselves
searching for something in the internet
searches are are ubiquitous in computer
science so every time I know
search algorithm comes along they just
go crazy for it and the genetic
algorithm is one such thing it
automatically in parallel every member
of a population of course moving one
tick at a time every time they pass
their genes is a very very slow process
remember evolution doesn't see organisms
evolution sees the species so it doesn't
see us it only sees us the moment we
pass our genes to our babies it is only
at that point that we enter into the
picture and every time one of these
virtual creatures passes its genes the
whole population moves a little bit in
this space a little bit in this space
and move in and blindly groping because
evolution doesn't have foresight you
cannot evolution cannot favor today a
wing a proto wing because it's going to
be useful 200 years down the road
evolution is opportunistic it only it
only catches what's now knew now but in
its blindness in its blind groping in
this space of possibility let's call it
a search space in the blind groping of
search space it's very effective by
finding new things and so it's being
used in industry as a searcher but
artists can of course use it as a
visualisation tool artists many times do
searches themselves they put date they
draw five variations of a facade for
instance then they step back pick the
best one and drop five variations on
that one and then they step back and
then they maybe pick another one and
they do five variations on that one and
that's basically what evolution does
except that it does it with hundreds of
drawings at the time so the genetic
algorithm is not going to replace the
artists clearly is simply one
visualization - one more visualization -
added to the increasingly complex kit of
tools that artists can bring now to the
job of creating new form but let's just
stop at that population thinking tells
us evolution is a search process and a
very effective search process I'll come
back to more details in a second the
second form of thinking I remember this
is a reasoning style it's a reasoning
style in which variation that has become
crucial in which multiplicities or
collectivities have become crucial
because evolution does not
happened with Adam and Eve and that
collectivity searches blindly a space of
possibilities the second form of
thinking that the list latches on or
barrels from science but then makes it
work for for for philosophy it's called
intensive thank you let me introduce the
word itself intensive in a
thermodynamics textbook when you open it
up and read for the interview work for
the definition you will find that they
defined a different they distinguished
extensive properties from intensive
properties extensive properties of
properties like length volume area
intensive properties of properties like
pressure speed density temperature and
the difference is that at least in the
textbook difference is that while
extensive properties can be divided in
space one can take a 1 meter one meter
long ruler ruler break it in two parts
and once end up with two one ends up
with two half meter rulers in other
words work areas can be divided volumes
can be divided temperature pressure and
so on cannot be divided it one takes one
gallon of water at 90 degrees
temperature and divides it into two one
has two half gallons but they're not to
have gallons of 45 degrees of
temperature yet to have gallons at 90
degrees of temperature now that doesn't
sound very exciting gonna but the Loess
sees more in this that is the textbook
definition the list is more in this and
he says forget about the textbook
definition is good but needs to be
extended philosophically first of all
let's reintroduce the word difference
that's the key word in delusion
philosophies main book is called
difference in repetition and the
differences are intensive difference he
says intensive differences drive
processes they are active they are
productive they for instance if you take
but let's go back again to our you know
a box of air divided into two parts then
with one heats up air on one side and we
have hot air and cold air separated by a
barrier you want opens a tiny little
opening in the barrier the cold air the
hot air is going to a
has the tendency just like the soap
bubble has intensity to minimize surface
tension here did the intensive
differences tend to be minimized there's
a spontaneous flow from one side to
another a HAP's the best example to have
in your mind as to what intensive what
an intensive map would be imagine a map
a map of Earth which shows the
continents with their coastlines and so
on that would be an extensive map most
maps are extensive they are based on
lengths the length of the coastlines the
areas covered by continents and so on an
intensive map is the map you see every
night in your material logical report
you know when you're checking out the
weather it's a map of his he has a zone
of high pressure and a zone of low
pressure for differences differences in
pressure a cold front a warm front
a mass of air moving at this speed
another mass of air moving on another
speed those intensive maps shows you the
couple system atmosphere hydrosphere for
what it is a place where process is
constantly occurring where intensive
differences move because you need to see
this maps animated zones of high
pressure moving one direction the loads
moving in another and the difference is
in intensity as long as they don't
cancel themselves out in our case their
own custom sets out because we have sun
shining on one side of the earth at any
one time keeping those differences alive
will drive process and we'll get will
give a birth to form this those
intensive differences give birth to
hurricanes and tornadoes give birth to
two good weather and bad weather give a
birth to different air currents like the
jet stream that have their own form on
their own dynamics
whereas extensive properties defined
final products defined that which is
already kind of done and finished of
course even the most done and finished
thing like like our continents are in
constant a a process because underneath
us all their gigantic self-organized
lava quan
mayor belts moving the plate of plate
tectonics against one another and making
the Himalayas go one millimeter a year
and having produced the Rockies you know
all the dramatic landscapes that we see
in earth when our travels are actually
produced by those gigantic conveyor
belts as they move this rock on top of
them but those gigantic when they are
built are also fueled like differences
in intensity by intensive differences so
this is the second time the word
difference appears here not as that it's
crucial that intensive differences are
there notice that in an intensive
difference is that the word difference
is being used in a different way than
say when I say this hand is different
than this watch because that is
different but that is only is a negative
use of difference all I'm saying is that
they lack resemblance to one another
that they have no similarities there's a
negative use of difference the list
wants a positive use of difference and
intensive differences give them the clue
now in biology intensive differences
manifest themselves in the process of
embryogenesis as genes at the moment you
have a fertilized egg that's beginning
to develop in an embryo and as the
different organs begin to form of course
the genes play a very important role
they're directing the the process but
most of the process is driven by
intensive differences in this particular
cases differences in concentration or
differences in density in the
concentration of certain morphogen
certain chemicals the chemical would
concentrate on a certain part of embryo
and at that point you know a limb would
emerge and then that limb would grow and
another concentrations of intensive
concentrations of a chemical that the
fingers will spread out and so on for
every organ and so and and and part of
the body so genetic information with its
differences with this variation depends
on the existence of intensive
differences in order to keep the process
going now another character
like of intensive properties and
intensive thinking that the list
mentions a lot is the fact that
intensive different intensive properties
are always characterized by critical
points at which matter spontaneously
changes architecture or forum the
perfect example here is to take water as
an example and then think of it water as
ice as liquid water and as vapour at
very specific points of intensity zero
degrees centigrade 100 degrees
centigrade water changes spontaneously
from one Architecture from one form from
one structure to another it crystallizes
at zero degrees centigrade or liquefies
it vaporizes and becomes steam or
remains liquid with all these different
possibilities then the liquid form has
its own line of intensity defining
different regimes of flow at very slow
speeds liquid water flows in a uniform
way at a critical point of speed it
begins flowing in a wavy or periodic
kind of way called convection and
another critical point to become store
veulent and it's ETS within ATS within
ATS is another spontaneous architecture
that emerges and those critical points
of intensity called phase transitions
are also crucial because they define a
lot of things in biology animals for
instance have different gates a horse
you can put in a thread mill and and a
mullet change the speed of the thread
mill are very slow speeds a horse would
walk then you start you know increasing
the speed you know there if you think of
a horse as mr. ed like Oh freaked out
like Wilbur or what's happening here
and at a critical point of speed the
force has to jump has to switch to
trucking and there are another critical
point us we well it has to City has to
break into galloping now walking
trotting galloping are three modes three
gates in both different muscles and
emerge spontaneously after a critical
point of intensity
now those critical points of intensity
are crucial to in the formation of of
the embryo and its development just
about every Oregon is born in a
concentration of intensity and branches
out or throws up you know uh veins and
nerve connections and so on following
phase transitions so DNA depends
crucially on the existence of an
intensive world of a world charged with
differences which is active and Morpho
genetically pregnant so to speak
finally there's topological thinking
here I need to get a little you know
more because it's mathematics I don't
start you know boring anybody here but
topology on like Euclidian geometry
involves a completely different
conception of space the simplest way of
exploring this is historically by
telling you how non-metric or
non-euclidean geometries were born when
Gauss and Riemann the 19th century
pioneers who created a deferred
differential geometry which is the
geometry of soap bubbles then they began
with a question of well if we have a
two-dimensional piece of paper that's
bent
say that's been found a curve like this
the way the Cartesian where you're
thinking about it was well you take a
two-dimensional surface you put it in a
three-dimensional shoebox
so to speak with this coordinates and
then you measure the rigid lengths or
distances that each point in the surface
have from the coordinate system and for
every point in the surface you gave it
an x y&z address that is the distances
from the x axis the y axis this
axis you always need a transcendental
space space that's one dimension larger
than whatever you're studying in the
case of two dimensions is a three
dimensional space in order to Metra size
in order to to divide to make it in a
way extensive and those thought do we
really need this I mean is there any
other way you're thinking about space
without rigid lengths and indefinite
coordinate systems and grids isn't there
a better way of thinking about it and he
thought well we already have the
differential calculus this is the third
appearance or the word difference
differential calculus of course
differential calculus triggers panic
sweat and everybody after having gone
the horrific math classes in high school
I remember I did you know I didn't
understand what the hell was that
supposed to be how was that relevant to
me I was good at math I got A's but I
hated my teacher he was boring and I'm
sure most of you did too but the
differential calculus actually is quite
special because it is a very is the most
powerful modeling tool in physics is
used particularly prior to quantum
physics and so on it was the most
important way of trying to capture the
dynamics of of processes material
processes in the world you're not to get
into into a whole thing about the
calculus you know a hacker is used to
black boxing whatever you don't want to
talk about you just just hide it and
think about what goes as an input what
comes as an output forget about how it
works so let's do that this black box it
and the only the only operator we need
is a differentiation operator it takes
as an input a rate of change the
velocity or speed with which something
is changing which with which something
is becoming different this is the third
sense of difference which is which
matters here for instance a rate of
change of position relative to time
that's speed that's velocity but it can
also be you can be an engineer that's
trying to calculate you're trying to
build a dam in a river you're trying to
calculate how much pressure that water
is putting on the dam and so you want to
see calculate the rate of change
of pressure relative to depth because it
will be more in the dip tip deeper you
get the more water on top of you have
the more pressure there is or it can be
any other rate of change and the black
box the differentiation operator spits
out an instantaneous value for that so
for instance maybe you're a ballistics
expert was analyzing a murder and you
want to know at what speed was the
bullet going right before it hit the
victim you know you don't want to know
the average speed of the bullet from the
moment I left it gone to the moment I
hit you want to know the instantaneous
value then the bullet had right before
it hit the victim right and so you use
the differential calculus you put in the
rate of change of position with respect
to time of the bullet out it comes the
specific moment at which the bullet hit
hit the victim so gals thought can we
use this to get rid of all those
coordinates and all those metric
Cartesian kind of a jail cells that the
confine our thinking about space and and
he can key the answer he came up with
was yes we can take our surface and
every point calculate the instantaneous
rate of change of curvature and that
will now give us is strictly with local
inflammation without going into the shoe
box and and metric sizing coordinating
this the surface it gives us strictly
with local information how fast that
surface is changing in his curvature at
every single point what that means is
that the surface first of all you can
kick out the three-dimensional space you
don't need it anymore you can do
everything with local information and
the surface becomes a field of rapidity
and slowness the rapidity or slowness
with which curvature is changing so for
instance if in a cross-section our
surface looks something like this over
here is not changing curvature at all so
the speed is very slow or not or none at
all
then begin speaking of speed it
accelerates decelerate and goes to
nothing again completely different I
d of what space is 70 then a God solved
the problem for two dimensional
manifolds as this bent surfaces are now
called his disciple Riemann was supposed
to be you know humble and nice and just
go for the three-dimensional case but
Hina he went for the whole enchilada
he saw the N dimensional case he solved
the case for all kinds of dimensions and
so he he began at that moment a
completely new differential view of
space do we now have three forms of
difference
Einstein of course became famous when he
thought hey no one has used this it's
been 70 years since Riemann wrote this
no one has used it and Newton assumed
that the entire universe was inside some
big shoebox called absolute space which
of course doesn't exist their shoes
they're not shoes that are that large
and Einstein thought maybe we can get
rid of the shoebox and instead calculate
the shape of space
strictly with local information using
this new ideas that's how he managed to
think about the fact that the Sun has so
much gravitational energy that in fact
it curves space around he came up with
that idea in the early twentieth century
no one really believed it except that
the math was perfectly clear but we
needed experimental evidence the only
way of of really proving this was well
there are certain stars that during the
day appear are right behind the Sun but
at night they are now in a different
position we can measure the distance
between the stars at night but during
the day the rays of light that come out
of the Stars and reach our eyes have to
pass through the gravitational field of
the Sun because the Sun is in front of
them and so the Sun should curve those
light rays and this two stars should
appear farther apart than they in fact
are because there should be a kind of
optical illusion due to this distortion
of space but of course you cannot
measure that distance because the Sun is
in front of it making you know ruining
the thing
so in 1919 there was a big eclipse
a total eclipse the Royal Society of
London sent observers the Royal Academy
of Paris sent of servers and all of them
went there to measure the distance
between the stars to see if Einstein was
right and Einstein was right to the last
millimeter he became a superstar so and
change the way we think about space
although the Sun space became
differential difference once more made
its entrance into the into the into our
ways of thinking and create a new way of
thinking about space just like intensive
thinking had created a new way you're
thinking about process and just like
population thinking had created a new
way you're thinking about evolution
three forms of difference three new ways
reasoning styles which are absolutely
necessary to run the genetic algorithm I
already said that somehow this is where
I tell my students you have to become
hackers because someone is going to have
to put this into code
someone needs to reproduce within the
computer this intensive this intensive
differences every branch of art has
different intensities deals with
different intensities those need to be
represented somehow in the computer
otherwise is not going to fly how's the
pelagic of thinking going to affect this
well topological spaces which are
similar to differential spaces like if
they accept it slightly slightly more
abstract but basically in the same
direction away from metric coordinates
and that kind of stuff have also been
used throughout the 20th century to as
representations for spaces of
possibilities you simply assign an
intensive quantity to each one of the
dimensions of the space and now let's
face each point in the space we come to
space of pause it becomes a possible
State for a given the system that you're
modeling the system that you're
representing then then you can then you
can explore whether that space is
structure or not whether every
possibility has the same probability of
occurring or whether certain states are
the most probable
of them all for it is the case of a soap
bubble unconstrained the most probable
state is the sphere and that will appear
in that space of possibilities as a
point which attracts all the different
processes and this is why soap film is
attracted in a way to a sphere that's
how a sphere concert soap film by being
a attractor of the process attractors
and repent and you know remember the
word chaos as in chaos theory it always
refers to chaotic attractors the
important word is attractors not chaos
because a tractors are it are features
of topological spaces which represent
tendencies in material systems and so
20th century physics particular
self-organizing complexity theory all
that kind of stuff of the last 30 years
depends crucially on using this spaces
hello I'm sorry I thought you talked up
you were talking to me so uh there's a
second let me just to get my train of
thought back here so why is this
important because the genetic algorithm
is a search algorithm it's a search
algorithm which lures a space of
possibilities so we putting together a
population of variable replicators with
any kind of filtering or sorting device
to play a role of selection pressure
creates a search process but what is
that process searching while searching a
space of possibilities but how can we
represent to ourselves that space of
possibilities well we with topological
spaces let me give you an example
biologists speak if they use the word
phylum phylum is basically one more
division in the tree of life the tree of
life begins by dividing into animals and
plants then animal and then that's the
first Kingdom that's the first division
and the next division done is called a
phylum we as vertebrates belong to the
phylum Chordata but besides that phylum
tends to refer to an ABS
tract body map a body map that can be
stretched and bent and fold
during embryological processes to yield
a giraffe or can bent and fold and
stretch to your window Souris it can be
bent and fold and pocketed and then
there to give a kangaroo and so on for
every single vertebrae all kinds of
designs come out of that space so the
space is rich with possibilities and of
course the abstract vertebrate cannot be
defined metrically because if you define
in terms of lengths the neck for
instance would have to be the finest set
let rigid length and then you would not
be able to get to stretch it to get the
giraffe or shrink it to get the
rhinoceros ah the limb of the phylum of
our but of this topological vertebrate
list column the limb cannot have any
definition of lengths or anything it's
just the connectivity how the bones are
connected to one another but that'll in
that abstract limb or topological limb
needs to be such that the genes can the
moment they get to the fingers they can
repress this finger from coming out
leave this one hanging and end up with a
hoof as in a horse or they can prolong
the lengthening of the finger process
and end up with something that cannot
grasp things anymore but that can serve
as a wing or it can sure you know it
stopped the growth at a certain at a
certain length and end up with a hand
and it's opposable thumb a vertebrae
limb has to have all those possibilities
at least in the body map of the xylem so
the idea would be too big to use
topological spaces as its basis of
possibilities to represent a phylum and
that would explain why the first artists
that began using the genetic algorithm
such as William Latham seem to run out
of shapes right away you know you open
the book of William Layton is very
impressive you see the generation you
see the genealogical tree showing you
how the thing evolved but then you begin
to get the feeling that he's running out
of shapes that he's not finding new
shapes that the search space is too
small and of course a search space of
the vertebrate phylum of the core phylum
Chordata is gigantic
and it can leave entire areas on
explored during you know in the Triassic
and Jurassic periods and so on the diet
when reptiles dominated they had all
this incredible variety of designs
velociraptors and t-rex and so on and
mammals we're a bunch of rat like Carrie
Bratz like creatures that you know if a
Martian would have come to word would
say well I don't give him any future man
reptiles are the ones who ruled here
look at the ugly rat snare then all of a
sudden a meteorite comes in wipes all
those ugly reptiles opens up all these
niches in any color in ecosystems for
mammals to begin differentiating and
begin to become you know everything from
whales and dolphins to bats and rats and
dogs and chihuahuas and so on an
incredible explosion of the science once
the space is open so space in fact we
have not exhausted it we don't even know
how many other designs are in that space
of possibilities so an artist using the
genetic algorithm needs to bring
topological thinking in order to design
search spaces part of what he or she
loses in terms of spell designing the
final product because now that is done
evolutionarily it gets recovered back in
the process of designing the very space
of possibilities that evolution searches
of course we have not yet have textbooks
on principles of topological design but
someone should write the book because
that is one of the one of the futures of
software if to begin training us to
begin thinking non metrically to begin
thinking in these different forms in
order to invent the spaces of
possibilities and then yeah unleash the
genetic algorithm to search it for us
while we are sleep maybe so if you know
when we wake up in the morning we can oh
my god did I do that I'm good I'm good
at any rate it's time for me to conclude
and so what I want to say in you know a
in conclusion is the neo materialism
that the list has proposed based on
these three modes of thinking is is
drastically different from the
we need to leave behind one that informs
Marxist remember it has informed the
thinking by the left the last 150 years
I cannot give you all the economic and
sociological and historical consequences
of this you can read that in my book a
thousand years of nonlinear history 1688
at a bookstore near you but there are
many consequences political consequences
of thinking like that because you need
to start bringing the environment you
need to start bringing the intensive a
processes that occur with or without us
but we need to watch out because
changing the temperature of the planet
for instance the wayward thing we are
right now warming the earth increasing
an intensive property without really
caring what all kinds of phase
transitions that can happen how our
epidemics are going to begin stretching
there you know if certain malaria which
right now sticks around all in tropical
areas as things get harder well
malarious also going to expand it's
going to be all kinds of phase
transitions that we don't know because
we don't care or apparently at least our
governments don't care
besides because we think in extensive
terms we don't think in terms of
critical points that can be reached and
then they are irreversible unless we
begin to change our way of thinking
intensive ways we're not going to be
able to do that but also topological
thinking and population thinking are
very important in ways that they're not
going to detail here so what the list
has done its liberated materialism from
what was basically an a priori process
dialectics invented by Hegel I admire
Hegel because he was gutsy you know you
had to give it to him when you read the
books you know someone who believed in
its own idea so much as to dialectically
generate all the concepts in a book in a
way that almost reminds you of
morphogenesis is admirable unfortunately
it's not true and so you can respect it
as a piece of philosophical architecture
that happened to happen to have a
beautiful monumental shape and at the
same time this wealth is history we need
something new something that that
connects with science but at the same
time that does not make slaves to
science
that allows to take scientific concepts
just like I just did go past the
textbook definitions which is all that
scientists need to derive all the real
consequences of this reasoning style and
then applying in our own philosophical
thinking I believe that is only with the
injection of this no materialism that
left will be rejuvenated I have great
hopes for it once we of course rid Jill
the lives of his crazy terminology
because one of the obstacles of reading
the laws is like if he doesn't think
that everything I just said is complex
enough he has to add different terms for
every chapter you know just to confuse
the hell out of us he probably thought
well you know I'm reading Spinoza just a
400-year philosopher I'm reading
liveness which is a 300-year philosopher
they can wait for me to hell I don't
have 200 years I want my the list now
and I want to clean and depose
modernized and so if we can manage to do
that and this is something that is very
experimental and we're artists as a
collective need to also be part of the
process we might be able to create a new
materialism that would inject new youth
into the old left thank you very much
we kind of take some questions
kama okay
well I mean I understand totally what
you're saying you're right now referring
to questions of style of course which is
goes beyond form because now is uh it's
a system of forums in a way the birthday
the example of the brushstroke is not so
good because then form remember the form
can be the form of the overall painting
the composition but it can also be the
form of the strokes themselves form has
to be seen at all these different levels
of scale in music from from appear you
know three or four notes to two entire
symphonies they will be formed
you know scaling up but you're right
style is one thing I left out but on the
other hand when we talk about the phylum
Chordata we're talking about a style
isn't it vertebrates a kind of style you
can tell them apart immediately from the
phylum Arthropoda which is insects and
insects in all the incredible variety of
forms form a style and so what the list
would say is styles didn't need us to
come into being is the other way around
Nature has styles and it is we humans
that need to learn from that because we
are part of it we are made out of flesh
and blood we are one of those styles and
and in order to assert our singularity
our uniqueness our difference it is
important of course that we need to
start considering all the different
forms of difference difference in
variation difference in intensity
difference in in the kind of
differential calculus that I just said
that exist in nature that power nature
and try to use it a lot of times we use
those things unconsciously we are simply
good artists that don't know how to
explain what we do but we can we can
tell about intensities we can tell
whether a painting strikes us or it's
powerful or on the other hand is subdued
because subdued own purpose and you're
playing with intensity it's not
necessarily using that vocabulary now
the last thing that the list would want
to do is impose a particular ideology on
art because artists are the search
process are you know they are the kind
of probe head at the tip of the search
and so the laws always kind of let them
pass Proust and Kafka litter creators he
followed them rather than say oh well
I'm better than Kathryn Berlin Proust he
quotes him us as people who saw who
drove humanity in a particularly intense
direction same thing he wrote a couple
of books on cinema he wrote about
Francis Bacon and painting he writes
quite a bit of about music in a thousand
plateaus with Felix qatari
so for him artists are that kind of
cutting edge of this process what he
would want is that when artists begin to
talk about their art that they would
have a better vocabulary instead of
deconstructing things when many things
they were the construction did they
don't even know what it means you know I
asked the question what the construction
means to every person that uses the word
deconstruction in front of me no one has
been able to define it what is that
telling and of course I was at the
dentist the other day opening a Cosmo
magazine
I don't normally read that but I thought
I may answer the questionnaire I was at
the dentist for godsakes and there was
there was deconstructing lipstick great
so what the list would want to do is yes
do art but the moment you start talking
about your art don't go hide behind
those funky words use words that mean
something because the last thing we want
artists to be doing is giving us this
pseudo explanations of their art cast it
in the latest terminology I saw a
handsome art yeah it seems that we as
species are in a place in history to be
able to to some degree to a large degree
edit and control what genetic mutations
were willing to accept or in most cases
than not deny I would say such as
Siamese twins or any other number of
diseases so on support' I'm interested
in what your thoughts are well I mean we
are you're absolutely right we are right
now at a point in history where we can
have it we have access to secrets we
don't know or are responsible to handle
let me just give it to you put it this
way what makes the species besides
natural selection is what it's called
reproductive isolation the moment to
reproductive communities that used to be
one community gets separated for
whatever reason a river change course
and now passes in between them and they
eventually begin to diverge and they
don't cannot mate with one another
imagine here the perfect example is
horses and donkeys horses and donkeys
can mate mechanically they can you know
hump they can actually a the eggs and
the sperms are compatible but the result
is a meal which is a sterile and
therefore the genes won't go through
there they are reproductively isolated
we are reproductively isolated from
chimpanzees in a much harsher way the
sperm one even fertilize the egg and
we're reported from whales and an even
greater sense mechanically won't even
work so reproductive isolation is what
gives species is enduring historical
identity but it is precisely because
it's not in essence it's a contingent
barrier it's something that is there and
it can be very harsh but it is
breathable because it's a historically
contingent thing all species are
individuals in the same way in which we
are individuals once we kill zebras when
we drive into extinction
there won't be anymore zebras which has
an ethical connotation much greater than
if there was a zebra hood out there
because then we can kill all the zebras
but then zebra hood will come back
because there's no zebra hood they won't
come back now the fact that the barrier
is historical means that we with
biotechnology can breach it as we speak
there is a factory in upstate New York
which is trying to manufacture a spider
silk spider silk spiders making that
nine different types of silk depending
on the weather some part for the
architects structural aspects of the
spiderweb orders to capture insects the
one particular type of silk is is
so strong that is stronger than Kevlar
Kevlar is a material they used to make a
bulletproof vests and so the scientists
are trying to produce spider silk right
but spiders because they're predators
unlike silkworms don't allow themselves
to be domesticated you know put 200
spiders come on produce some silk and
they won't do it so what did they do
well they figure out the protein that
makes this change that we call spider
silk then they figure out the genetic
code of it
they found the gene in the spider they
took that gene and implant it into a
goat right now when I first heard about
this I thought that the result was going
to be spider goat you know a goat
dressed in blue and red going bad but
enough nothing
nothing as exciting as that on the other
hand what's happening here is that the
goats this genetically engineer goats
express that protein but of course they
don't have any use force for spider silk
so they just they kind of excrete it in
their milk and then what what is a
factory that actually exists right now
as we speak right
they take the milk they separate the
milk apart from the other stuff and then
they extrude it through tiny little
pores to create spider silk now it all
seems like oh wow another triumph for
Humanity well let's wait and see we
don't know what happens when you begin
breaching this historically contingent
barriers but that are there not for a
purpose but in a complex arrangement of
things you begin fooling around with
this you know and of course it's just a
matter of time before genetic
engineering begins up you know being
applied to humans it's going to be
illegal for a long time but then tattoos
are illegal you know and all kinds of
cosmetic changes that you can make to
your body are illegal and yet that
doesn't stop people from doing it right
today we have people who go to Streck
Tech Star Trek conventions you know and
then they learn how to speak Klingon and
they teach their kids how to speak
Klingon ha ha ha
and one day those guys may want Rhino
genes in their forehead because they
think you know Klingon Rhino kind of
foreheads are very cool and I'll bet you
they're gonna find someone who's gonna
do it illegally
so our own barriers are not safe and
what was once going to happen once we
start fooling around with those things
we don't know this is probably when
another reason why genetic algorithms
could be useful because they could allow
us to begin visualizing prior to that
Klingon future why would happen once we
begin transplanting rhinos or rhinoceros
genes into our foreheads another
question yes absolutely and in fact the
laws mentions Zen Buddhism as one
particular branch with several times in
his writings as the one religion that
would be the most compatible with what
he's talking about and not only Deleuze
there is a person his name is Francisco
Varela who began as a neuro as a
cognitive scientist neuroscientist and
began to apply this ideas about
self-organization to the tribes of
neurons to the insect colony so to speak
that in our brain and and
self-organizing to thoughts and images
and feelings and he was a Buddhist he
died recently but he obviously found
that there was a very direct connection
between certain meditation techniques
and certain certainly certain uses of
your body in which you used your your
breathing rhythms to pulse certain other
rhythms and then focus the mind in
certain ways to experience precisely the
topological that which is non-metric you
know which the patterns in nature which
go beyond the actual products and inform
the process that create products so I
myself am a little bit more because you
know I come from Mexico very Catholic
kind of country you know with variable
buddy Jesus Christ and so on and somehow
you know religion has always been one of
those things I want to get away with
from but a if there was one religion
that I would respect or that would be
fine compatible with this materialism
would be would be Buddhism certainly yes
I'm sorry I'll get back to you yeah you
know the worst thing that could have
happened to Hayek was when Reagan
adopted him I'll bet you the Hayek was
turning turning in his grade going on my
god that bad actor and now he's
president I'll tell you how that
connects with that I believe that Hayek
is right in talking about markets or
self-organizing things what he was wrong
about is to think that corporations
belong to the market I've written plenty
about this they have many essays that
you can get from the net just type the
Landa and economics and there's at least
I call them anti markets precisely
because they are more like bureaucracies
than they are like markets any any
product that you find in your house
that's not produced by a small producer
you know in a real competitive situation
with hundreds and hundreds of people
competing is producing a corporation
which is closer to the central planning
of a socialist state than it is to
anything that Hayek ever talked about
there are very few areas of the world
today that actually display economic
self organization that can name them
with my one hand even with a horse's
hand there's the third Italy that region
in Italy between Milan and Venice called
Emilia Romagna you know cities are
Madonna Bologna it's about thirty
thousand small businesses competing
against each other is capitalist to make
no mistake about that but small because
they are driven by design
and they know that the moment you bring
managers and accountants and a hierarchy
and you become a joint-stock company and
so on the designers are the last ones to
have a say in how the company's run so
here we have 20,000 this is a figure
that I got from you know might might
have changed but several thousand small
businesses that do design you know the
Italians how good they design they in
this particular region they do textile
design ceramics but also industrial
design the design machine and it has a
completely different dynamics you know
you still have bosses and workers but
because the typical size of a factories
a hundred people
I mean ova ova ova firm is a hundred
people a motivated worker who is also a
designer can become his or her own boss
the moment the firm grows too large it
splits into two and where there's much
less barriers to entry for workers to
becoming bosses so there's a lot more
social mobility they have not eliminated
it's not a perfectly equal society but
then again perfect equality needs to be
enforced by a super powerful state and
all you're really doing is creating a
class of enforcers which is what went
wrong with Marxism there are certain
parts of Silicon Valley that are like
that particularly those that grew around
Apple Computer when Apple Computer was
started by two hippies and $1300 in a
garage they they created the Apple 2
with an open architecture which meant
that people could design boards to plug
in the boss and they did not try to
corner all the profits they realized
that if they opened it akatosh industry
of hardware designers software designers
and so on was going to merge around it
and they seated Silicon Valley that way
of course Apple eventually grew to large
there's face transition there a phase
transition is when you cannot finance
yourself from bank credit and you need
to sell stock options you need to go
public the IPL the famous IPL that
everybody went crazy during the bubble
and the internet at that point 1984 they
kick jobs out Steve Jobs they brought in
a manager from Pepsi Cola as if selling
computers were the same thing as selling
sodas only less fizzy you know I don't
I don't even know what kind of mentality
does that of course Apple went down the
tubes steadily ever since they had to
bring jobs back at the end of the
nineties to kind of infuse a little bit
of life into it you can find those
places but if one if one uses the word
capitalism as a blanket war for
everything where money is used and
there's and there is a division of labor
and so on you will never see them or you
begin coming up with silly labels like
post Fordism tu-tu-tu-tu-tu refer to
them instead of making an inventory of
all the equal economic experiments are
going on in the world which ones are
viable which ones are exploitative you
know lit and getting more serious about
this I believe that you have your hand
yeah Hey triggering the diversity he is
looking for the minimum surface with
which it will structurally they only the
most efficient one also separately
absolutely yeah but I'll tell you how
you can okay but let me just answer that
first part now go back to the job yes
but that means only the only that means
is that there are spaces of
possibilities or what they call face
spaces come in different forms and
shapes the simplest ones have a single
optimum those were the ones that
survival of the fittest evolutionary
theories assume they assume that
everything was like a soap bubble fry
ought to begun with those because those
are the simplest one to handle and
you're right there is something about
the optimizer engineer you know in fry
auto that kind of limits them but we
don't have to be limited like that we
can we can study topological thinking
the way it is and they're to show that
the simplest possible space is only the
extreme case we have all kinds of sorry
all kinds of all the space is much more
complex with much more possibilities
like the phylum for the vertebrates and
therefore we don't have to fall for
optimizing rationality we can we can in
fact make it into a special case and
then say yes you guys are right but
that's not the way reality works for
instance Hayek that he just mentioned as
a conservative Hayek used to believe
that the market has only one point
that's optimum the pointer which demand
and supplies cancel each other out
exactly before there is no wasteful
excesses or wasteful deficits but of
course markets are not like that markets
have at least periodic equilibria ups
and downs of swings and down swings and
that yet another type of equilibrium
another type of attractor today we know
that they are chaotic attractors which
actually have internal divergence in
them so they are exactly the opposite of
steady-state and we know that all of
these come in bunches
this is what topological thinking is
just in this century to show us the
great diversity of spaces that we can
have so even though I agree with you
that Frei Otto fell for that
and the Gaudi to remember Gaudi how he
calculated day the facade for the
Sagrada famlia he took a little pieces
of cord of threads and hung little
little bands with sand or something in
them you know I saw it at the Museum you
know of course it's upside down you need
to see a right set up but he was using
morphogenesis to design and he does a
lot of that in all of his buildings in
fact when you see his his style
it's almost topological there's
something either even though he didn't
know any math and he'd do everything in
a much more kind of naive kind of way
intuitively he intuited this spaces and
so the idea here is not to condemn
something because a few artists went for
the simplest type of spaces Frei you
know fra Ocho needs to be considered a
starting point rather than the end of a
line you had a second question okay
that's right but you know again we are
in a much better position right now with
extremely powerful computers you know
with memory becoming cheaper and cheaper
you know I just bought a new Mac with
Maya for two thousand dollars when it
used to be a forty thousand dollar a
piece of software things are getting
cheaper our you know you used to get go
into debt and get a bank loan if you
wanted that tool or use it at school
today you can buy it and have it and the
sellers of software are listening to
artists because they are beginning to
realize that the last thing they want to
do is give you a tool that imposes its
own style on you they want them the
tools to be flexible they're hiring
artists as consultants not because they
want to do any favors but because they
want to sell more software but that is
it they're moving in the right direction
in the direction of complexity did I see
a hand over there okay excuse me no but
no no no but what why but unfortunately
I haven't seen it so I have to see it
though okay that's all thank you very
much
you
[Music]